[Musique]
isolés dans leur case ou parfois dans
des ehpad loin des yeux mais pas loin du
coeur au lendemain de la période de
confinement les personnes âgées restent
parfois loin de leurs familles
un retour à la vie normale ou les
relations humaines ne doivent pas être
oubliés nos gramounes sont le plus grand
13 ans ce sont des trésors qu'on doit
faire vivre parce que les gras mono
leurs doigts cette solidarité et à
travers la convention consignes avec
orange est bien seul ya de solidarité
l'appareil nettement il apparaît il
éclate au grand jour
le développement de ces relations
humaines sur le territoire est au centre
de la préoccupation du département
pourtant il faut limiter les risques
auprès de nos gramounes
le numérique est l'une des solutions on
utilise en fait la puissance du gros
pain pour être solide
mais cette solidité n'en aurait aucun
sens si on était complètement déconnecté
du territoire aujourd'hui on est
complètement ancré sur le territoire
on emploie mille réunionnais et on va
continuer à le faire et on travaille
avec de nombreuses associations avec de
nombreuses mairies et également avec le
conseil départemental évidemment pour
travailler sur ce territoire qui nous
est cher six cent mille réunionnais
devraient être touchés par ces visages
sur une télé locale accompagne et la
digitalisation des personnes loin du
numérique est l'un des objectifs les
intérêts sont donc ici commun car la
famille reste le point clé une manière
de garder le contact du lien social et
familial l'humanité qu'on a en nous elle
rejaillit elle ressent elle s'exprime et
c'est tant mieux assis
[Musique]